لا يزال الجرح مغطى بالضمادات والقروح يتعافى من
عملية جراحية طارئة لطفل يبلغ من العمر 11 عامًا، مثل أبو
هادي، وهو تذكير دائم
بالصدمة التي تعرض لها هو وأصدقاؤه عندما كانوا
يلعبون في الخارج بالقرب من
منزله في مدينة غزة عندما قالوا إن
غارة جوية
[  موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
ضربت [
معجب كبير بكرة القدم لعب في
الأكاديمية المحلية وكان يحلم بأن يصبح
لاعب كرة قدم محترفًا [موسيقى] لاعب في القاعة هو مالك الكافنا البالغ من العمر 12 عامًا،
فرت عائلته من منزلهم في ب  هان
بعد تلقي تحذير من
الجيش الإسرائيلي، انتقلوا من مدينة إلى
أخرى بحثًا عن الأمان، يتبعه في كل
مرة المزيد من الضربات الجوية
[موسيقى]، وهو
ما بدأ البعض هنا
يتأقلمون ببطء مع
واقعهم الجديد. يصل المزيد من الأطفال المصابين إلى
مستشفى ألاكا مار  كل يوم هو الآن
المستشفى الرئيسي العامل في غزة،
ويترك آخرون في حالة من
الانهيار التام. يوم الاثنين فقط، تم نقل المزيد من الجرحى
إلى هذا المستشفى بعد أن أصيبت مدرسة غير مدارة
تستخدم لإيواء
الفلسطينيين النازحين في مخيم بور للاجئين،
ولا يزال عدد القتلى الناتج عن ذلك  من
غير الواضح من هو المسؤول عن
هذا الهجوم المحدد، وتزعم حماس أن
الجيش الإسرائيلي قصف المدرسة،
على الرغم من أن سي إن إن لا يمكنها التحقق بشكل مستقل من
هذا الادعاء، ولم يستجب الجيش الإسرائيلي بعد
لطلب سي إن إن للتعليق، ولكن مع
تكثيف الغارات الجوية والقصف في
شمال غزة، أصبح أطفال غزة كما هم.  وفي كثير من الأحيان
تدفع القضية الثمن الباهظ
مع آلاف الجرحى والقتلى
وتضيع الآمال في المستقبل الآن في سحق سي
إن إن في القدس